thank you
because I want people to notice that
when he tried to get up initially he
could not get up on his own
I know none of us are big on his
policies and the people watching this
are not big on his policies and
everything else but but this is really
getting depressing at some level right I
do not want president Kamala Harris she
makes absolutely no sense when she
speaks she would just try and solve
things with a bunch of you know
confusing Venn diagrams that only she
understands a whole big laughing about
nothing it would be very confusing so I
do hope that Biden makes it of course as
I'm sure we all do to the uh to the end
of his term